the surgeon will perform a hysteroscopy
to view the inside of your
uterus hysteroscopy can be used to
diagnose or correct a problem in
the uterus without the need to make an
incision in the abdomen the uterus is a
hollow organ in the lower abdomen where
the baby grows during a  pregnancy
each month during
a woman's childbearing years the inner lining of her uterus
called the endometrium accumulates
extra blood and tissue to prepare
for pregnancy
if pregnancy does not occur the extra tissue
is shed through the vagina
during menstruation
a diagnostic hysteroscopy  may
be done to evaluate the causes
of abnormal uterine bleeding
investigate possible causes of
infertility or repeat miscarriages
or look for benign or non-cancerous lumps
in your uterus such as fibroids
polyps scars or malformations an
operative hysteroscopy may be
done to remove benign lumps
from the uterus
obtain a  tissue sample or biopsy
of the p  walls of the uterus
place an intrauterine device iud or
place small devices in the
fallopian tubes as a form of
permanent birth control before
your procedure you may receive
general regional or local anesthesia
the doctor will start by inserting a
speculum to separate the walls of the
vagina then the doctor will pull
the cervix towards the entrance of the vagina
then the doctor will use instruments
called dilators to open the
cervix
the doctor will guide a hysteroscope a
thin device equipped with a
camera and a light through the vagina and
into the uterus the camera will transmit
images of the uterus on a screen
the doctor will inject gas or liquid to
expand the uterus making it easier to
locate abnormal tissue in your
uterus in a
diagnostic hysteroscopy the doctor will use the
listeros he copied to examine the inside
of the uterus in  an operative copy
the doctor will insert small
tools  while passing through the sternum
to take a biopsy removing a lump such
as a polyp or treating other problems
after the procedure
your doctor may recommend pain relievers you should be
able to return to your normal activities a
day or two after your
procedure you may have
cramps  smooth and a little
blood flow for several days